Hey traders, it's Mike here, and in this
video, I'm going to continue talking
about the uh order flow exhaustion entry
model. And you know, the point I want to
make in this video is not all exhaustion
prints are equal. So, you know, which
ones do you trade is is the
million-dollar question. And today in
the S&P's, there was uh there was two
that kind of stood out here. There was
one here,
one here. This one, you know, market
just started going up, but then sort of
fell down,
um and then went sideways. This other
one here, we had nice run up and uh made
new highs and continued to make new
highs. So, what's sort what's the
difference, you know? Is this a bad
trade and and this is a good trade? You
know, in hindsight, you say, "Oh, yeah,
well, this was the good trade." But to
be honest, you know, this trade right
here, this first one, um you know, it's
it started out as looking like a
potentially good trade. So, let's uh
let's sort of break it down here. So,
you know, we had just made a new high
about uh 20 minutes after the cash open,
and we started coming off. This is our
swing low, and you know, when you look
at sort of the move that happened prior,
uh
you know, this was the cash open over
here.
This
this bar here, you know, then we sort of
worked our way up. We pulled back. This
is about a 50% retracement from here to
here, um right in here. So, you know, it
wasn't a bad entry.
You know, it's it's just one of those
trades that just didn't work out. It
started to go up, and then it just sort
of petered out, made that new low, and
then went sideways. But when we're
looking at the order flow, right? Let's
just sort of take it back here a step.
So, we hit the high,
okay? And you know, anytime you're at a
high, you got to be looking for a
reasons to potentially get short. And
you know, we we hit the high, very
strong positive delta 400. Next bar came
in, 200, 400. So, you know, these three
bars
near the high, you know, it's got nice
strong positive delta, then strong
aggressive selling came in. You know,
we're looking at nine minus 991 in the
delta.
Um this next bar has got a small delta
of five and then another strong bar
minus 494.
And then this bar opens up, right? And
you can see it's a little green candle.
So, that means that one point we're
looking at a big red candle down. Um,
obviously the delta the min delta was
minus 375.
Okay.
But then later in the bar it reversed.
The aggressive buying came in and we
ended up with a positive delta of 171.
So, you know, with with that in mind,
potentially you're thinking that hey,
you know what? Maybe this market um,
isn't going to sell off because again,
you know, we had some strong delta minus
991 minus 494. And then it was looking
like a strong delta minus 375 at one
point, but then it reversed.
I do like that it is a swing low
right here.
And you know, if you also just take into
account, you know, just
uh,
here, right from this cash open up to
this high, you know, we're looking at
about a 50% pullback, which is, you
know, something that you you would like
to see um, for the market to keep uh,
continuing going higher. Okay. So,
again, you know, if you're looking to
buy there, it's not a bad trade. It's
just unfortunate that it stopped you
out. Um, you know, you'd be looking to
get long somewhere in here. Um, you
know, your risk is here, just below
here. Then you're stopped out a few
minutes later. And again, you know, what
was interesting, you know, we had this
strong negative delta earlier, minus 991
minus 494. And even into this bar here,
the minus 375, but it reversed, started
going up. But then the selling started
reappearing, okay? Right in here as we
push down. Minus 124 minus 282 minus
917. So, you actually have a a negative
delta surge, meaning the aggressive
selling is getting stronger,
but
what happens, right? You you got that
strong selling, you're looking for this
market to keep going down. It it
doesn't. It halts right here. And this
green candle goes inside, right? Which
is not a good sign if you're looking for
the market to keep selling off. So, we
had some strong selling here. Market
didn't really go any go much lower.
Next little grouping here, more strong
selling. This time we did go a little
bit lower, but then
the scary part is the market comes right
back with this green candle with a big
strong positive delta. So,
you know, you know that even though
you've had two attempts by the market to
push lower,
right? With that aggressive selling,
the first time didn't really happen.
Second time it did push lower, but then
immediately it came it snapped right
back, right? It didn't go sideways. It
immediately just recovered everything.
Okay? So, then what happens a little bit
later,
you know, this is about 9:00, about
9:13,
we get this market going sideways. Okay?
Right in here. Now, we this is the value
area of this green candle. So, it's you
can see it's sort of drawn out. And we
keep sort of testing it, right? 60 140.
And then seven, you got another
exhaustion print coming in right here,
right? Sort of on the upper end of this
support area, which is the value area
high of this candle, this reversal
candle. All right? Now, again, what we
had here earlier with the strong deltas,
minus 991, minus 494, this little delta
surge going on right here, minus 124,
minus 282, minus 917.
You get another little delta surge
taking place right here, minus eight,
minus 249, minus 460. So, you get a
little bit of selling pressure coming
in, coming into a support area.
And again, it's a delta surge, right?
But this time it's a negative delta
surge cuz it's the negative delta that's
increasing.
But it doesn't go any lower in the next
bar. In fact, the next bar starts going
higher.
Then we go sideways for a bar, and then
we push back down.
Okay? And again, we sort of hit that
support area. But again, when we hit it,
it trades just seven contracts, right?
That's a sign of exhaustion. The The
very minimal amount of contracts that
can be traded, obviously, is just one.
But seven is a small enough number, you
know, it trades 3,578
contracts in the bar. But in this case,
it trades just seven, so we know
that
aggressive sellers aren't interested in
moving the market lower. And it's had
one
two
three times with these pockets of
aggressive selling.
And just sort of taking it on the
surface, you know, you could just see
between two and three
on two, you know, it was -124, -282,
-917. Second time, it was just eight,
-8, -249, -460.
So, even this 460, it's about half of
the aggressive selling that we saw
earlier. So, you're starting to get the
picture that even though there's sort of
these little waves of aggressive
selling, even though the aggressive
selling is coming in, it is weaker than
that exhaustion print right here. That
seven is sort of that kiss of death. And
then the market goes up to new highs.
Again, you know, where you going to be
getting long from? 98. Where's your
stop? Just below.
You know, what is that? 92 and a half?
You know, yeah, that's what? Six points.
But look at this move that took place.
Okay?
You know, we we went up from
you know, this area right in here
around, you know, 97 and a half, 98. Got
all the way up to 7508, pulled back a
little bit, made another run back up,
you know, into the teens. So, again, you
know, you
you're risking eight points. This was a
10-point move, little bit of a pullback
before it shot up. Um
shot up more, right? You see, it would
even got all the way up into 20. So,
again, you know, what's your risk?
Right? Your your risk is just it's just
this, basically that bar itself.
And again, you're looking for a move
from 97 all the way up into to 17.
Right? And that's
basically from about 9:15 up until about
9:50.
So,
you know, not even an hour.
So, just sort of getting back to, you
know, what what sort of the point was,
this is not a bad trade, the first one.
Here, yeah, it would it would stop you
out. Okay, you you just got to live with
that that you're going to get stopped
out from time to time. Again, it it's
not a bad trade. I don't want to say,
"Oh, you know, you're going to not take
this trade because of this." No, I mean,
there were there was some aggressive
selling. That's just had to the market
had to sort of work its way out. Again,
you know, we're up at the high of the
day. It's not uncommon to see some
selling coming in. There was just a
little bit of selling pressure that took
place in this bar, but as you can see in
the next bar, it just recouped it back
very quickly.
And, you know, to be honest, if this bar
didn't happen, you know, we would have
just sort of gone sideways here anyway
before making that move that you're
looking for. Um you know, that's you
know, the market's just going to do what
the market's going to do.
But again, this is not a bad trade, per
se, even though it did stop you out.
There was just a little bit more of
selling that had to be executed in the
market by the other market participants,
but
you get your next signal right here and
you could catch that move. You know, and
and again, you know, what was
interesting on this move here
again, if you were just to you know,
just sort of play with the replacements
again, that's a 50% replacement right
here, right? It's literally one tick
through from this low to this high and
then it starts moving back up. You know,
I I I love the 50% replacement. Um you
know, and I know traders and strategic
traders recently we've been spending a
lot of time talking about um the 61
.8, which is also good. You know, I'm
I'm
you know, with my background, with my
understanding of market profile I've
always
followed the 50% replacement anyway.
Um but you know, when you're coming back
into a level, just as I said over here,
right? This
it's just unfortunate you got stopped
out on this on this first trade. But
again, that is also from the cash open
to this high up here, the high of the
day.
This is also about a 50% replacement. It
did eventually pull back. Um
you know, down to you know, the 71%
before going back up. But again, you
know, you you the market respects half
back.
You know, do a search on half back in in
uh market profile and you'll understand
the importance of it. All right? So
again
it's not just about taking any
ex you know, small volume print at the
bottom of the bar.
You know, you want to put it together
with what you're seeing in the delta.
Right? In here.
In here.
Okay? But then you could see even in
here on this last on this second trade
the delta was increasing 24 102 240. So
the aggressive selling was decreasing
and the aggressive buying was
increasing.
Does that make it stronger? Well, it's
giving you more reason to get into that
trade, okay? In this case here, again,
we had that selling. I mean, the five
is, you know,
inconsequential
in the sense that, you know, it doesn't
give you much direction to go off of,
but minus 991, minus 494. Yeah, it is
decreasing a little bit. Obviously, it
got down to minus 375 before ending up
at 171. And so, you're looking for a
reversal
anyway with the exhaustion print and the
way the delta is sort of decreasing. It
just came in with this one bar with
extra selling.
Okay? So,
again, you know, there are going to be
times that you do take a hit, take a
take a loss, but then you just prepare
yourself for the next opportunity that
comes along.
Okay? And the second one was a beautiful
opportunity. Very little drawdown. I
mean, look at this. If, you know, once
this this is your signal bar, right? Cuz
it's got your exhaustion print here,
it's got your deltas down here. Um
you're getting long, you know, somewhere
in here around 97 and a half, 98.
It doesn't even pull back into this area
where you got long from.
You know, there always there's a saying,
right? The best trades
work quickly.
This is a perfect example of the best
trades working quickly. It was a quick
shot up
with with absolutely no drawdown in the
trade.
So,
you know, if you like what you're seeing
in here, be sure to check the
description. You know, we talk about
trades like this
every day inside of Strategic Traders.
Um there's a link
down below. So, I'll catch you guys on
my next video.